[Applause]  hey birthday besties you ready to party  tonight yeah  that's your best friend you got a  knitter go oh god oh my god you're so  gross you Oh looks like you guys are on  tap for another [ __ ] show tonight if you  guys screw up I get to bounce your ass  from the lake not gonna happen  hey guys where should I put these  fireworks this is gonna be easy  there are party boys between us I'm  gonna ask her to marry me tonight maybe  I've been looking for the perfect moment  maybe you should just find you know a  time before the doctor man wipes are up  you're right it's time that we go off  script a little bit toss your  inhibitions is it's time to boogie  promise me nobody dies tonight and last  one yet  I knew they couldn't resist I knew it  it delights and on my wait grade come on  I got a proposal to stop is gonna be fun  [Applause]  [Music]  there it is Sun is finally gonna die  [Applause]  I'm on a boat no whenever that song  you